welcome to befriends.com be friends
is an ambitious nfp project around
characters
that have traits that i believe in so so
much
that i want people to aspire to
they also happen to be a token to a
conference that i'm going to put on
every single year
called vcon v conference a multi-day
event
that is going to rival some of the
greatest conferences in the world around
entrepreneurship marketing ideas
creativity competition meeting new
friends it's a community
it will be my great honor to create an
ecosystem around the access tokens that
are a huge part of this project
hangout time group stuff bowling tennis
bubble hockey
video games dinners brunches and then
remind me what 555 gift goats
correct these are people who are gonna
literally put in your address
and stuff shows up hang out hawks five
times a year
in a zoom for three years 15 sessions
that's crazy
how many access tokens are there just
one-on-one with me
108. just think about that that's the
number one request i get
every single day i think it's all about
ip
i think everything is all the pipes are
dumb what you fill it with
is everything and even in my field of
like hip-hop
i think like when we look at mickey or
disney or we looking like hello kitty
there's so much i've been thinking about
creating characters
because i've always loved disney i've
always loved to get along gang and
snorks you know how many times i
reference wuzzles you know what wuzzles
are i buy stuffed animals
mugs with pop culture on it all the same
game that was built for this moment so
now i've got to create mine this was
reverse engineered
for the vayniacs what they were called
when we did wine library
tv the vayner nation my community
the people i interact with all the time
it was very important to me when i
structured this
that it was a culmination of many things
in my life my interest around
creating characters my ambition to push
certain attributes in humanity
a conference that i've been dying to put
on for years
and access when i sat back and said
what's the biggest thing i can give them
time you want to go sit courtside with
me in the next game here we are i'm
trying to
build a blueprint for everybody that has
an audience
of how to do a proper nft project
you